[Music]
bass peasants the way we write numbers
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten and I see because we've got ten
fingers yeah so I guess you would just
come from very much
well this has been useful so let's write
that down I just think everyone should
know that it doesn't have to be that way
base 10 is just irritating so 12 is an
amazing number because you can divide it
by 2 you can divide it by 3 and 4 and 6
and get whole numbers so it's very
special in a decimal model it would be
much easier to use currency anything
that you were trying to measure if he
wanted to have a third of it or a
quarter of it would make it much easier
to do and that would make young
children's experience of maths smooth
them bases are all about at what point
you go from just having a single
character to represent a number to
having two characters for us in the
decimal society we do that when we go
from nine three to ten and we use
numbers that have already been used we
use a one in a zero and even considered
that but actually there are no symbols
pass line because then it's just exactly
so base 12 would mean that you need 12
symbols 0 3 2 9 as we have and then two
more symbols as well 11 and it's only
now when we get to 12 that we have to go
into 2 columns 1 0 and it would look
like telling me it would represent
travel I've never done this so four
times table in base 12 okay 4 times 1 is
4 4 times 2 is 8 4 times 3 is right
that's right yeah cos 1 love tell me it
won't be that it we know that's a 1011
and then we start again because we've
got like we've got a whole thing here of
12
oh it keeps repeating sometimes tables
work more nicely in base 12 somewhat
more nicely in base 10 I guess there are
more of them to work nicely in base 12
because there are more numbers that
divide exactly into 12 2 3 4 4 6
that's kind of what makes it useful for
writing fractions kind of with nice
things after the decimal place 1/3 which
is really difficult to write normally
nor point 3 3 you could wipe nicely
music-based 1 if this means 4 12 but you
still couldn't do 7 it's not rare I
don't think to have to share something
mostly people or four people and base 10
is just irritating I wouldn't say we
have to use the number system 10 why
must we use the number system hmm if you
go back to classical antiquity you tend
to find that other systems were more
predominant the sexagesimal system of
the Babylonians for example base 60 so
rather than having columns with powers
of 10 like we have they have columns
with powers of 60 so there's a units
column there's the 60s there's the 360 s
[Music]
360 is very close to the number of days
in the year that's where this idea of
using 60 comes from the fact that we
have 60 minutes in an hour comes from
the Babylonians we convert in and out of
basic C quite a lot when we work out how
many hours things up I didn't even know
is doing fancy mathematics Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
there are some legacies of previous
counting systems in everyday life when
we're measuring things we use lots of
different bases
[Applause]
civilizations have switched between
bases throughout history and we could do
it again and the entire world has grown
up with base 10 you'd have to like
completely rewire like I've gotten
strange into being like oh let me get my
base 12 times tables I really want to
switch to page 12 so that when I'm using
maths it's a more pleasant experience
why can't we be using the best base
it'll be so confusing for me and for
everybody else but I can sort of see on
a mathematical level why base 12 Oh
[Music]